poco más de tres horas ha durado la
reunión entre angela merkel y vladimir
putin aquí hemos con una reunión en la
que se han tratado muchos temas y muy
complicados en los que berlín y moscú
mantienen posiciones casi enfrentadas
como por ejemplo la guerra en el este de
ucrania donde merkel ha vuelto a pedir
más responsabilidad a parte rusa
mientras que vladímir putin acusa del
empeoramiento de la situación en donde
únicamente a la parte ucraniana en
cuanto al opositor al ex en aval ni
encarcelado aquí en rusia merkel ha
vuelto a mostrar su apoyo al ex yo naval
y mientras que vladímir putin asegura
que naval cne no está en la cárcel por
sus ideas políticas sino por haber roto
la ley rusa se han tratado otros muchos
temas como por ejemplo el gasoducto nord
stream 2 la situación política en
bielorrusia o la crisis de los migrantes
entre bielorrusia los países bálticos y
por supuesto la situación que se está
viviendo ahora mismo en afganistán tras
la salida de las puertas estadounidenses
esta ha sido una reunión que ha sabido a
despedida estatal una vez que veremos a
angela merkel a quien rusia como
canciller y ambos líderes putin y merkel
han coincidido que pese a que la
situación entre rusia y el cliente se ha
empeorado notablemente estos últimos
años ambos líderes han sabido en todo
momento mantener
desde hielo abiertos